et en direct il y a quand même la
liberté vous remercie d'avoir un
multiple
[Musique]
sans surprise en iran
l'ultraconservateur ebrahim raïssi est
déclaré vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle victoire dès le premier
tour avec 61 95 % des voix et déjà salué
par le président russe vladimir poutine
le taux de participation lui est le plus
bas jamais enregistré pour ce scrutin
48,8 %
le 19 juin est à marquer d'une pierre
blanche dans l'histoire américaine c'est
désormais un jour férié qui marque la
commémoration de la fin de l' esclavage
le président biden
et de son adjoint kamala harris on a
promulgué le texte aujourd'hui une
victoire pour le mouvement black life
d'amateurs qui fait entendre sa voix
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
[Musique]
le japon lève demain l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
certaines restrictions seront en
revanche maintenues et ceux à près d'un
mois de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
de tokyo restriction qui pourrait
sérieusement limiter la présence d'un
public local dans la compétition les
spectateurs venant de l'étranger ont
déjà été interdits pour l'événement une
première dans l'histoire olympique
[Musique]
d
bonsoir bienvenue et si vous ne
retrouvez sur rtl france ebrahim raïssi
c'est le nom du nouvel homme fort d'iran
donné favori cet ultraconservateur de 60
ans a remporté l'élection présidentielle
dès le premier tour avec 61 95 % vous le
voyez sur ces images aux côtés de son
désormais prédécesseur hassan rohani un
scrutin boycotté par l'opposition et
salué aujourd'hui par le guide suprême
pour ali khamenei je cite le grand
vainqueur de cette présidentielle est la
nation iranienne qui s'est levé contre
la propagande des médias mercenaires de
l'ennemi qui est ebrahim raïssi le
nouveau président iranien son portrait
est signée élèves masculins
ebrahim raïssi 60 ans est une figure
austère de la république islamique comme
religieux familier des hautes sphères de
la politique iranienne
l'ultra-conservateur gravitent dans le
cercle proche du guide suprême iranien
l'ayatollah ali khamenei dont il a suivi
l'enseignement et qui l'a propulsée sur
la scène politique jeune procureur
implacable
actuellement chef du pouvoir judiciaire
il est aussi avec sa riche fondation
religieuse à stan qods razavi à la tête
d'un empire économique
pour ses détracteurs ebrahim raïssi
serait l'incarnation de la répression
son nom est régulièrement associé aux
exécutions massives de détenus de gauche
en 1988 dans lequel ebrahim raïssi nie
toute participation en 2017 alors qu'il
se présentait à l'élection
présidentielle face à hassan rohani le
président sortant n'avait pas manqué de
le lui rappeler
ebrahim raïssi figurent aussi sur la
liste noire des états unis
sanctionné par washington pour
complicité de graves violations des
droits humains parmi ses convictions le
nouveau président fustige notamment le
relâchement des moeurs
il est arc-boutée sur la séparation des
sexes et préconise le retour en force de
l'enseignement du chiisme au sein de
l'université
sur le plan politique sa campagne s'est
appuyé sur la lutte contre la corruption
et la pauvreté
sur fond de ras-le-bol général face à la
crise dans un pays riche en
hydrocarbures mais soumis aux sanctions
américaines
l'amélioration de la situation
économique est une promesse séduisante
mais le vrai défi désormais pour ebrahim
raïssi remplacer hassan rohani qui finit
son mandat avec un niveau d'impopularité
record
et s'il fait ses preuves l'ultra
conservateur pourrait se placer comme un
possible successeur ali khamenei
l'ayatollah à la santé déclinante et
accéder ainsi au titre de guide suprême
et le passage de témoin n'aura pas tardé
entre hassan rohani ebrahim raïssi et
deux hommes ont tenu aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse commune et ils
disent souhaiter avant tout une bonne
entente entre le peuple et le
gouvernement
je sois loué le président élu
aujourd'hui est une figure qui ces
dernières années de par sa position dans
la magistrature est pleinement conscient
de la situation dans le pays
il a assisté à toutes les réunions
importantes du pays
il est conscient des problèmes culturels
des problèmes de sécurité des problèmes
économiques
et d'autres problèmes nous étions
ensemble lors de réunions il connaît les
hauts et les bas de notre époque
notamment la période des sanctions et du
coronavirus nous allons certainement
utiliser les expériences du gouvernement
actuel avec la coopération de monsieur
roy ni et de tous les membres du
gouvernement j'utiliserai certainement
les opinions points de vue expériences
et rapport des ministres et
fonctionnaires estimé pendant cette
période d'un mois et demi et je demande
à tous les experts et tous les penseurs
de nous informer de leur point de vue
opinions et idées
l'une des choses que nous poursuivrons
dans le gouvernement de notre peuple
si dieu le veut sera que tout le monde
joue un rôle puissent les élites et les
experts bénéficier de leurs précieuses
idées réflexions
côté réactions internationales le
président russe vladimir poutine a
rapidement félicité et brahim raïs et
pour sa victoire à la présidentielle
iranienne
j'espère que vos activités à ce poste
élevé contribueront au développement
ultérieur d'une coopération bilatérale
constructive dans diverses domaine et de
notre partenariat dans les affaires
internationales
cela répond entièrement aux intérêts des
peuples russe et iranien et va dans le
sens d'un renforcement de la sécurité et
de la stabilité régionale
c'est un jour dont la communauté noire
américaine se souviendra le 19 juin
devient jour férié commémorant la fin de
l'esclavagé aux états unis le texte joe
biden et sa vice-présidente kamala
harris long promulgué aujourd'hui
partout le mouvement black like the
matters a fait éclater sa joie même si
son combat n'est pas encore terminé
maxime hébert walid ben ali au texas une
fresque géante pour célébrer le jun
teens contraction de joints et de 19 en
anglais une référence au 19 juin 1865
une date symbolique aux états unis qui
marque la fin de la guerre de sécession
et la libération des derniers esclaves
du texas
la presse que se concentrent sur
différents points de l'histoire le passé
le présent et l'avenir elle montre
l'évolution de john teens l'importance
de la libération des esclaves et de la
liberté ainsi que la direction que nous
espérons prendre à l'avenir dans
certains états du sud
le 19 juin est célébrée depuis longtemps
ce mardi le congrès à approuver la
création de la journée nationale
d'indépendance du djoon tiff
dans un rare moment d'unité politique
quarante huit heures plus tard joe biden
promulgué officiellement un jour férié
dans tout le pays alors que nous
commémorons l'histoire du jean ping
comme nous l'avons fait il ya quelques
semaines avec le massacre de tout ça
nous devons apprendre de notre histoire
et nous devons enseigner notre histoire
à nos enfants parce que cela fait partie
de notre histoire en tant que nation
cela fait partie de l'histoire
américaine
cette journée est souvent célébrées par
des défilés des concerts des fêtes de
quartier comme ici dans l'état de
washington
et certaines entreprises on en fait un
jour chômé pour leurs salariés
[Musique]
ces dernières années les bavures
policières ont ranimé le sentiment de
lutte dans le minnesota une
manifestation avait lieu ce vendredi
pour réclamer des réparations pour les
descendants d'esclaves
une autre bataille à mener pour la
communauté afro américaine
le djoon teens représente non seulement
la commémoration de la fin de
l'esclavagé en amérique il ya plus de
150 ans mais aussi le travail en cours
qui doit apporter une véritable équité
et une justice raciale dans la société
américaine ce dont nous sommes capables
en bref cette journée ne célèbre pas
seulement le passé elle appelle
désormais à l'action
je souhaite à tous les américains un
joyeux jenkins une commission du congrès
américain a adopté en avril un projet de
loi visant à réparer une partie des
torts causés par l'esclave âge des
experts devraient être chargés de
proposer des indemnités aux descendants
des millions d'africains ramener de
force aux états unis pour être
définitivement approuvé ce texte devrait
être adopté par la chambre des
représentants puis par le sénat
on reste aux états unis où la cour
suprême a rejeté les accusations de
travail forcé d'enfants dans le cacao
entre nestlé et contre nestlé kharg il
elle se dit ne pas être au compétents
temps dans la mesure où les faits ont eu
lieu en côte d'ivoire si maliens ont
porté le dossier il affirme avoir été
capturé dans leur enfance et maintenus
en esclavage dans des plantations
ivoirienne d'après eux nestlé kharg il
était au courant et ont fermé les yeux
pour maintenir leur avantage compétitif
margaret kimberley raid et chris black
quatre jeunes d'arrêt porte reprochent
aux états de jouer un double jeu
il faudrait rendre illégal le b
naissent des grandes entreprises
américaines avec tous ceux qui recourent
au travail des enfants parce qu'ils
disent toujours il ne travaille pas pour
nous ce n'était pas notre ferme vous ne
pouvez pas nous accuser il faut y
remédier par la législation des d'autres
grandes entreprises nuisent aussi
beaucoup aux gens surtout l'année
dernière il disait black lips made
certains se mettait à genoux déclaré que
leur lieu de travail était anti racistes
alors que ce n'est pas le cas c'est l'un
des nombreux cas où les états unis font
preuve d'hypocrisie concernant le sujet
des droits de l'homme en donnant carte
blanche aux grandes entreprises pour
pratiquer toutes sortes de choses
terribles dans le monde entier
l'argent fait la loi les grandes
entreprises sont entendus par les hommes
politiques et ne sont pas tenus
responsables comme elle devrait l'être
une rencontre qui pourrait peut-être
amené à une sortie de crise au liban
c'est celle de joseph bourrel chef de la
diplomatie de l'union européenne et
d'hassan diab premier ministre
démissionnaire dix mois après le pays du
cèdre n'arrive toujours pas à former de
gouvernement et s'enfonce dans une crise
économique sans précédent
le dirigeant européen appelle donc le
liban a trouvé un accord avec le fonds
monétaire international le fmi qui avait
déjà stoppé des négociations l'an passé
faute d'entente avec beyrouth
face à l'impasse le conseil européen se
dit prêt à prendre des sanctions de
l'abonné leadership moustiques les
dirigeants libanais doivent prendre leur
responsabilité et doivent adopter les
mesures nécessaires sans plus attendre
un gouvernement doit être formé et des
réformes mises en oeuvre immédiatement
forme simplement emilio les ans les
tarifs en cela un accord urgent avec le
fonds monétaire international sauvera le
pays de l'effondrement financier que
vous connaissez au liban vous avez
besoin d'un accord avec le fmi
il n'y a plus de temps à perdre vous
êtes au bord de l'effondrement financier
dès 19h including ce conseil de l'union
européenne à envisager d'autres options
dans des sanctions ciblées
bien sûr nous préférons ne pas emprunter
cette voie et nous espérons ne pas avoir
à le faire mais la décision est entre
les mains des dirigeants libanais à dos
les deux chiens elles sont venues des
quatre coins du pays
plus d'un millier de femmes se sont
mobilisés ce samedi pour demander à
rochette tayyip erdogan de revenir sur
sa décision de retirer la turquie de la
convention d'istanbul retrait qui sera
rendu officiel le 1er juillet prochain
le président turc a déjà suscité
l'indignation en mars dernier en se
retirant du premier traité restrictif
texte qui vise à prévenir et à combattre
la violence à l'égard des femmes
écoutez ces témoignages notre espoir
prend toujours sa source dans nos luttes
dans nos organisations
aujourd'hui des femmes sont venues de 70
province pour former nos cortège
nous croyons à la force de nos
organisations et que la décision soit
annulée ou non nous allons poursuivre
notre combat de toutes les façons
possibles jusqu'à maintenant nous avons
toujours réussi à les faire reculer et
je pense qu'ils vont devoir encore plié
car cette fois les femmes sont très
fortes et agissent tout ensemble toutes
les femmes ne demandent qu'une seule
chose que le retrait de la convention
d'istanbul soit annulé et que la
convention soit appliquée avec
efficacité en france apparaît
précisément mobilisation aujourd'hui
contre les licenciements et la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
le cortège est parti du siège du medef
et devra rejoindre matignon mais l'accès
a été interdit par un arrêt préfectoral
des manifestants mobilisés pour la
seconde fois à l'appel de la
si j'étais tui france entreprise touchée
par un plan de licenciement qui concerne
600 salariés
ce mouvement est soutenu par des
syndicats d'autres secteurs l'hôtellerie
l'industrie ou encore le social mise en
péril par la crise sanitaire et ces
restrictions
si on veut y arriver mais dès qu'on
arrive à être tous sont donc on aimerait
que déjà y ait du monde dans la rue et
ensuite un message sur le terrain
politique
parce que comme on dit il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui est distribué aux batteries
donc quelque part on est gentil avec
notre propre argent et ça c'est
intolérable
on voit bien que la crise permet à
certains de profiter de la période pour
licencier à tour de bras et c'est ça
qu'on dénonce en disant qu'il faut une
autre oeuvre une autre politique qui
justement papa d aide à gogo pour les
entreprises et qui derrière vont en
profiter plus anciens ce qui me met en
colère c'est de leur dire écoutez vous
êtes ces entreprises à vous les avez
aidé les avait aidés à s'installer vous
leur avez donné de l'argent de l'état
notre argent
eh ben ça veut dire que si ces sottises
et l'a ensuite elle elle dépose des
pilons alors qu'il n'y a aucun argument
et économiques ces sociétés là doivent
rembourser et c'est ce qui permettra
peut-être d'indemniser les salariés qui
se font licencier ce dimanche sonnera la
fin du couvre-feu dans l'hexagone
l'épidémie de covile 19 régresse même si
des inquiétudes se font de plus en plus
insistantes face à la menace du variant
indien vous allez le voir la prudence
reste de mise malgré tout illustration à
marseille où les pompiers leur nouvelle
brigade canine assurent la sécurité de
l'aéroport de marignane avec un
dispositif anti comique qui fait ses
preuves
lucky faire avec isabelle ferrière chien
pour la détection convient de ne vous
inquiétez pas avec son flair hinse l'arc
scrute méthodiquement chacun des
passagers de ce vol venus de l'étranger
son objectif détecter le moindre signal
olfactif d'une contamination coville 19
en place depuis maintenant un mois le
dispositif cynophiles des marins
pompiers de marseille a pris ses marques
ce berger hollandais travail avec la
brigade depuis plus de six ans et pour
cette opération il a pu bénéficier d'une
formation au plus près de la maladie on
a fait travailler directement sur les
marins pompiers de chez nous qui étaient
contaminés on a pu bénéficier de
l'espace de quelques temps pour
expliquer aux chiens ce qu'ils
recherchaient en fait lui mettre devant
lui dès les gens contaminés pour qu il
puisse rechercher cette odeur spécifique
de réactions physiologiques aux polices
et les maladies ou les cancers le
diabète genre de choses sont peuvent
être repérés par le chien ça a été déjà
fait dans le passé
là on a appliqué un peu cette cette
façon de travailler pour locaux vides
qui est notre actualitté déjà connue et
utilisée pour ses capacités à détecter
les drogues l'argent les explosifs ou
les armes
les brigades canines se montre aussi
très efficace pour les maladies mais
reste encore indissociable de la
technologie ce qui est important c'est
que vraiment le chien ne peut pas être
indépendante de notre cellule mobile
d'intervention biologique qui va
confirmer qu'elle a pour confirmer le
finalement le diagnostic du chien le
chien m'a pourra scanner environ 50
personnes en quatre minutes c'est
beaucoup plus rapide que n'importe
quelle machine efficace en plus mais
derrière la confirmation se fera de
toute façon par une machine pour
transmettre ben justement aux organismes
comme la rs ou la caisse d'assurance
maladie pour dire oui effectivement la
personne est bien positive par contre il
faudrait énormément de temps pour avoir
un test pcr pour tout le monde par
contre le chien c'est très très rapide
une détection plus rapide mais aussi une
sécurité supplémentaire dans la lutte
contre la transmission du virus les
l'efficacité aucun problème on est à de
l'ordre de 97 % de sensibilité mais il
est très rare de retrouver des gens
positifs puisque il est demandé aux
passagers de fournir un test pcr avant
d'embarquer
donc théoriquement ne devrait jamais en
trouver après duke le test date de 48 ou
72 heures peuvent tout à fait contracté
la maladie dans ce laps de temps
ça c'est possible hinse lac et le
premier chien de la brigade avoir été
formé quatre sont désormais
opérationnels dans les points d'entrée
c'est à dire les aéroports les gares ou
les ports maritimes
cinq autres sont en formation l'objectif
est d'atteindre une brigade de quinze
chiens pour pouvoir faire face au trafic
qui va reprendre progressivement le
japon s'apprête à lever ce dimanche
l'état d'urgence sanitaire certaines
restrictions restent néanmoins maintenu
et cela un peu plus d'un mois de
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques de tokyo
compétition interdite aux spectateurs
venus de l'étranger et peut-être même
bientôt au public local et l'âme
medjahed
au japon les mesures sanitaires
pourraient paraître un peu paradoxal le
gouvernement a annoncé la levée ce
dimanche de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour neuf départements de l'archipel
nippon
les restrictions sanitaires en revanche
sont toujours d'actualité et nous avons
décidé de lever l'état d'urgence à
partir du vent joint à tokyo ainsi que
dans les préfectures de hokkaido daiichi
de kyoto d'osaka de hyogo et d'okayama
et hiroshima et de fukuoka
le nombre d'infections au niveau
national est en baisse depuis la mi mai
si les signes laissent penser que le
système médical est sous pression en
raison d'une autre expansion des
infections nous réagirons avec souplesse
renforçons les mesures comme celles sur
la vente de boissons alcoolisées ou les
restrictions sur les grands
rassemblements pour tokyo et six autres
départements les restrictions sont en
partie maintenu les bars et restaurants
seront à nouveau autorisés à servir de
l'alcool mais ce jusqu'à 19 heures
uniquement certains regroupements tels
que les coursayres ou des événements
sportifs seront autorisés avec un public
réduit d'autres départements qui ne
connaissent pas la même amélioration
comme celui d'okinawa doivent patienter
encore jusqu'au 11 juillet les variants
constitue la principale menace d'une
recrudescence des infections
à un mois du début des jeux olympiques
la situation sanitaire reste toujours
une préoccupation majeure pour les
organisateurs et les autorités
la direction des opérations djo se
voulait déjà catégorique cette semaine
sur deux possibles sanctions en cas de
non respect des règles sanitaires
depuis plusieurs mois l'organisation se
veut rassurante mais intransigeante
vis-à-vis des restrictions mises en
place
un parti pris qui a su convaincre la
population désormais moins réticentes à
la tenue des jeux
toutefois d'après le gouvernement niveau
des mesures drastiques pourraient être
prises si la situation venait à
s'aggraver dans les prochaines semaines
le monde compte désormais plus de 82
millions de réfugiés et déplacés et
c'est le chiffre à retenir un du dernier
rapport du haut commissariat de l'onu
pour les réfugiés
et c'est un record pour 2020 les enfants
de moins de 18 ans représentent 42% et
des personnes déplacées de force
françois estime fitch c'est l'un des
paradoxes de 2020 malgré la fermeture
des frontières en raison de la pandémie
de kobe 19,3 millions de personnes
supplémentaires ont dû fuir les
persécutions la violence et les conflits
depuis la fin 2010 9 au total ce sont
donc 82 millions 400 mille personnes qui
ont été déplacées à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur de leur pays un nouveau
record nos impacts locaux vides 19
semble n'avoir eu aucun impact sur
certains des principales causes
profondes qui poussent les gens à fuir
la guerre la violence la discrimination
ont perduré quoi qu'il arrive tout au
long de la pandémie
c'est pourquoi dans le rapport de cette
année qui concerne l'année 2020 il y à
une nouvelle augmentation
nous sommes passés de 79 millions cinq
cent mille réfugiés et de déplacés à 82
millions 400 mille soit une augmentation
de 3 millions tous étaient tous des
styles and increase of traîner sur ce
chiffre 42 % sont des mineurs deux
personnes déplacées dans le monde sur
trois sont originaires de cinq pays la
syrie le venezuela l'afghanistan le
soudan du sud et la birmanie
concernant les pays d'accueil près de
trois quarts des personnes déplacées
recensés par le hcr ont été prises en
chasse
je pars des pays voisins avec trois
millions sept cent mille personnes
conséquence de la guerre civile en syrie
la turquie pour la septième année
consécutive le pays accueillant la plus
importante population de réfugiés au
monde tandis qu'au niveau européen c'est
l'allemagne qui a accueilli le plus de
réfugiés avec un million deux cent mille
personnes et le hr fait état de
nouvelles situations de déplacement nous
avons vu l'année dernière et cela
continue et d'ailleurs tout au long des
six premiers mois de 2000 21
nous avons vu de nouvelles situations de
déplacement au nord du mozambique
sept cent mille personnes ont été
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays
au sahel où nous estimons qu'il y ait
environ 3 millions de personnes
réfugiées ou déplacées dans 750 milles
au titre de ce seul rapport donc 2020
ensuite vous avez le tigre et au nord de
l'ethiopie nous estimons que jusqu'à un
million de personnes pourraient avoir
été fraîchement déplacées par le conflit
qui a débuté en octobre dernier et c'est
une tendance qui continue selon le haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés 99 des
plus de 160 pays dans le monde ont fermé
leur frontière à cause de la pandémie
avec le risque d'une augmentation de
personnes déplacées dès lors que la
pandémie s'atténuera et que les
frontières commenceront à rouvrir de
total à bailleur rapport publié cette
semaine par plusieurs ong alerte sur à
l'intensification du lobbying des
multinationales et ce alors que la
commission européenne doit présenter
d'ici la fin de l'année une directive
pour mieux encadrer les entreprises face
au respect des droits de l'homme et de
l'environnement
les précisions avec katia technique la
commission européenne va plancher sur
une directive sur le devoir de vigilance
des entreprises sa mission s'assurer que
les multinationales et leurs filiales
respectent les droits humains et
l'environnement
elle vise un contrôle sur toute leur
chaîne de production y compris les sous
traitants qui peuvent parfois être
nombreux très lointain à l'abri des
regards et des réglementations
il ne suffit pas de fabriquer de
l'électroménager encore faudrait-il
s'assurer que ce ne sont pas des enfants
qui extraient les métaux aucune forêt ou
un villa
je n'ai pas détruit pour cela et pour
remplir ses obligations les entreprises
devront bien entendu contrôler et
surveiller audités changer de sous
traitants et cela coûte cher
sentant le vent venir de nombreuses
sociétés ont dépensé des centaines de
milliers d'euros en lobbying l'eau angie
corporate europe observatory vient de
produire un rapport sur ces entreprises
qui ont tenté de vider la directive de
sa substance
nous avons finalement mis la main sur
des dizaines de documents de lobbying
interne de la dg justice dont nous
rendons compte pour la première fois ici
qui avec le lobbying auprès du parlement
européen révèle les tactiques les
arguments utilisés par ces entreprises
tant en public qu'en coulisses quelques
exemples croustillant avec business
europe association patronale européenne
qui défend les intérêts d'entreprises
privées de 35 pays auprès de l'union
son président est nul autre que l'ancien
patron du medef pierre gattaz business
europe a écrit à la commission pour
faire part de ses inquiétudes vis-à-vis
de cette directive
pour lui le devoir de vigilance devra
imposer une obligation de moyens mais va
des résultats il propose en toute
simplicité d'exclure le changement
climatique de la directive
c'est vrai que c'est un petit détail les
températures extrêmes la mort des forêts
la montée des eaux
il faudrait inclure dans la directive
seulement le dernier rang des sous
traitants pratique on risque moins d'y
détecter du travail des enfants où tu
travailles fort c'est business europe
plaide pour l'apparition d'une clause de
sauvegarde qui leur éviterait des procès
au cas où il aurait mis en place des
mesures volontaires de responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises le rse comme
cela si ces garde-fous s'avèrent
inefficaces pour prévenir des entorses
aux droits humains ou des pollutions ils
seront intouchables
le principe c'est l'intention qui compte
quant au géant de l'agro chimie bayer
celui là même qui a racheté monsanto il
sponsorise un débat sur le site politico
son pdg donne son avis sur cette
directive
elle devrait de se mêler que de droits
humains c'est vrai ça le climat
l'environnement après tout ce n'est pas
si important pour un fabricant de gm et
de pesticides qui dessine les insectes
on saisit bien l'enjeu
et quid des iem autres associations
d'entreprises qui regroupe les intérêts
de coca cola danone mars l'onglet nez
les nike et unilever il suggère de
proposer des mesures incitatives pour
respecter les droits humains comme si ça
ne devait pas être un pré requis et puis
il ne faudrait soumettre aux risques de
procès seulement les atteinte sévère aux
droits de l'homme et encore pas sur
toute la chaîne de sous traitance en
2020 l'association européenne du cacao
elle aussi est créée la direction
générale de la justice au sein de la
commission européenne ils veulent aussi
des clauses de sauvegarde tiens tiens
cela ne serait-il pas pour éviter des
procès bien sordide comme celui de huit
personnes
ancien enfant esclave qui ont poursuivi
mars monde les nestlé entre autres
compagnies pour avoir contribué à l'
esclavage illégales de milliers
d'enfants dans les fermes du cacao
et oui être tenu responsable d'un délit
qu'on a contribué à provoquer quel
concept subversif total qui à cause de
la loi française est l'objet de deux
plaintes pouce de son côté pour que la
loi européenne soit moins contraignante
que la loi hexagonal et le cabinet de
lobbying dont elle est membre souhaite
que le changement climatique ne soient
pas intégrés aux mesures logique pour un
pétrolier les rédacteurs de la directive
arriveront-ils à tenir le cap face aux
pressions des entreprises
à l'autre bout de la chaîne les victimes
des sous traitants et des dégâts
environnementaux aimerait bien pouvoir
aussi faire du lobbying
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous dans une demi
heure pour un nouveau point sur
l'information reste avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arctique cet endroit où l'eurasie
l'amérique du nord et l'asie pacifique
se rend compte qu'on est en train de
devenir un lieu de tension